[Musik]
dann fragte ich sie warum sie nach
herztod keinen anderen genommen hat
dieser satz aus bernhard schlinks neuem
roman olga führt uns einerseits genau
ins herzen dessen was das buch
beschreibt und andererseits führt uns
auf eine falsche spur
denn man hört ja schon da ist ein ich
erzähler zu gange aber den ich erzähler
gibt es nur im mittelteil dieses buch
ist es besteht aus drei teilen
und die sind jeweils unterschiedlichen
erzählperspektiven erzählt das ist ganz
ungewöhnlich verschlingt der sich
bislang immer auf eine perspektive
beschränkt hat sein thema ist immer ein
gewisser weise die deutsche geschichte
das ist auch bei olga so da bekommen wir
das lebensschicksal einer frau erzählt
die 1883 geboren ist und anfang der
siebzigerjahre stirbt also über fast
neun jahrzehnte hinweg wird erzählt und
das große rätsel dieser figur und in
gewisser weise fast wie ein krimi ist
dann auch das buch aufgebaut besteht
darin warum sie sich nach einer ganz
großen liebesaffäre mit dem eben
erwähnten herbert sich nicht noch einmal
verliebt und ich darf leider gottes
nicht im geringsten andeuten wie dieses
rätsel zu lösen ist denn es wird
natürlich hier drin gelöst denn damit
würde man zu viel preisgeben von dem was
den spezifischen reiz dieses buches
ausmacht und der liegt vor allem darin
dass man die konstellation der figuren
zueinander zwar sehr begeistert nach
verfolgt aber dann doch bis zuletzt
eigentlich nicht komplett versteht wenn
er jetzt noch ist kehrt hätte das ganze
ein bisschen wagemutiger zu formulieren
sich nicht auf seine doch etwas zurück
genommene schreibweise zu beschränken
und den großen emotionen die gerade auf
olga seite entstehen auch eine
entsprechend bilderreiche und vehemente
sprache zu verleihen
dann wäre das ein unglaublich
wunderbarer roman geworden so ist es ein
sehr lesenswerter aber auf das richtig
große buch von bernhard schlink warte
ich ungeachtet des riesenerfolgs vom
vorleser und von anderen büchern von ihm
immer noch